eu tô aqui hoje porque um dia eu decidi
não mais contribuir com nenhum tipo de
ideia serviço trabalha que pudesse e de
encontro e que pudesse não fazer bem as
pessoas
na verdade eu decidi utilizar a energia
criativa apenas onde eu pudesse empodera
e promover a transformação
eu nasci numa cidade chamada mundo novo
que fica no interior da bahia 4 sertão
quase chapada e apesar de amar a vida
aqui na cidade e adorar os encontros que
são paulo tem para oferecer e esse é um
deles
é eu cresci sendo o antigo caminho do
interior da bahia
uma menina que tem como descendência um
tataravô que veio da áfrica trouxe um
arco e vendia santos uma para a avó que
era parteira uma bisavó que tem 102 anos
hoje e está viva e mora dessa
provavelmente rezando por mim e ver vai
filhinha e que apesar de não ter
aprendido nem ler nem escrever
ela me ensinou a frase que pra mim é o
que me pega nos momentos difíceis ela
disse eu vou fazer de tudo pra não
chorar
é preciso ter coragem para enfrentar as
coisas da vida também que se uma família
de circo tios uma avó que foi professora
aprender a fazer cocada licor de
jenipapo joaquim teodoro vocês conhecem
essas coisas uma volta que foi baterista
jogador de futebol
sapateiro tinha uma banca na feira e uma
mãe que desde muito pequena
gostando de estudar ela descobriu que
ela podia trocar livros é um dos livros
e os pequenos de romance que tinha de
bolsa para poder ter mais acesso ao
conhecimento e mais acesso à informação
essa mulher se tornou bancária criou
duas filhas sozinha com a ajuda da
família dos amigos e foi dela que houve
desde muito nova as palavras que que
fazem de mim ser a mulher que eu tô aqui
hoje
quando eu era pequeno eu sempre quis
deixar meu cabelo solto e as pessoas
queriam fazer chiquinha fazer trancinha
bota debaixo de um chapéu
minha mãe dizia pra todo mundo olha
se a menina quer deixar o cabelo solto
deixa o cabelo da menina no mundo e eu
acho que todos esses valores a todas
essas crenças e sentimentos de alguma
maneira atravessaram a minha escolha
profissional e atravessaram a a minha
intenção eu sou design design hoje eu
sou diretora criativa no brasil mas o
designer e eu costumo resume design como
atividade onde é possível materializar
coisas no mundo materialista sentimentos
dá significado a eles
eu acho que a nossa capacidade de
projetar coisas no mundo ela está
totalmente ligado à nossa capacidade de
sonhar
eu sonhei estar aqui hoje eu estou aqui
hoje e eu acho que a gente perdeu a
capacidade de sonhar porque a gente
também perdeu a capacidade de olhar para
o outro de olhar a história do outro de
pensar a diversidade brasileira e isso
eu falo quando eu olho pra cada um de
vocês aqui eu vejo isso uma diversidade
que ela é muito mais além do que está
dentro de você mas é o que atravessa no
mundo é a memória do seu corpo à memória
da sua história que o processo de
criação é espaço de poder mas isso
resume basicamente o motivo da minha
vinda aqui hoje para falar pra vocês
o processo de criação espaço de poder
porque o espaço de escolha e quando a
gente escolhe a gente pode escolher pela
libertação por libertar as pessoas
os modelos libertar as pessoas das
prisões
eu tive a sorte de encontrar no meu
caminho pessoas que estão para se jogar
esse sonho comigo construir no brasil
uma plataforma que hoje é um instituto
que conecta pessoas que através da
criatividade está mudando o país e que
tem como missão e inspirar em poder a
comunidade criativa brasileira para que
sejamos todos agentes da transformação
mas aí quando eu falo isso eu sinto que
as pessoas pensam palmas é uma coisa
meio tópico é impossível eu falo será
que eu sou tão impossível assim eu tô
aqui e eu acho que a criatividade ela
foi responsável por mudar minha vida não
só a minha em um ano de projeto a gente
tem ao acho que sim histórias mais um
pouco mais de cem histórias contadas de
pessoas que perceberam que
aplicar energia de trabalho e criar
coisas têm um impacto tanto material
contém material na vida das pessoas
a gente passou muito tempo discutindo o
descarte do objeto do produto
mas o que acontece com as coisas que
estão por trás das imagens dos objetos
que a gente queria
existem existe violência as violências
simbólicas que a gente não consegue ver
e que essas violências a que desperta é
talvez um dos principais doenças do
contemporâneo que é uma crise de
representatividade ea triste quando a
gente vê por exemplo a menina que não se
enxerga dentro da sua casa porque seu
cabelo diferente da sua irmã e ela não
se dá bem com a família porque ela tem
ali um problema de não se reconhecer ou
quando a gente tiver um filho tem um
problema com o seu pai porque fez uma
outra opção sexual ou de mudança de
gênero ou quando a gente vê uma mulher
destruir sua autoestima o que a roupa
não cabe no corpo dela na estrutura do
corpo dela
então essas são só algumas das coisas
que a gente pode falar sobre essa crise
de representatividade ea gente precisa
pensar que a representatividade sim
representatividade importa é que a gente
precisa olhar para a diversidade
brasileira como esse caminho em busca
dessa construção de um mundo um pouco
mais diverso que dê conta da nossa
história
pra finalizar eu queria deixar para
vocês três provocações qualquer
responsabilidade que nós agentes
criativos temos quando materializam as
coisas que dão sentido ao mundo que a
gente de fato está fazendo quando a
gente aplica desde de trabalho para
mudar a realidade que a gente tanto
critica ficar no facebook todo mundo
sabe mas o que de fato a gente está
fazendo a gente chama isso de micro
revoluções é o que a gente faz aqui
dentro de casa com o outro com a nossa
comunidade com nossa família e dizer que
processo criativo espaço de poder porque
liberta processo criativo espaço de
poder porque ele dá conta dessa memória
do nosso corpo e eu deixo o convite aqui
pra que a gente pense um pouco sobre
isso porque o processo criativo espaço
de poder a gente pode e deve ocupar la
obrigado